qui a dit que l'industrie française
était forcément vouée au déclin au
teilleul dans le sud de la manche la
société qu'une gueule produit un million
deux cent mille palette
chaque année l'entreprise revendique une
gestion de bon sens certains diraient
une gestion à l'ancienne et elle ne
manque ni de clients ni de perspectives
la maison qu'une qu'elle ne laisserait à
personne d'autre le soin de choisir et
d'abattre ces résineux elle exploite des
forêts dans le grand quart nord-ouest de
la france
les rondins sont ensuite rapatriés vers
l' usine du teilleul
c'est un principe la société a toujours
d'abord misé sur elle même pas de sous
traitance je ne sais tu pas dans la
culture maison séparée culture maison
tout ce qu'on peut internaliser on
l'internet c'est-à-dire de la coupe de
l'arbre jusqu'à la fabrication de la
palette jusqu'à la fabrication et le
transport aussi que le transport on dit
le métier sinistrés
une qu'elle continue d'exploiter sa
propre syrie afin de débiter les rondins
et fabriquer les planches dans toutes
les dimensions nécessaires partout
l'organisation est millimétré
pendant que les six des coupes dans un
atelier voisin des lames de rechange
sont affûtés en permanence elles sont
remplacées pendant la pause déjeuner
sans aucune intervention extérieure
lafuteur le technicien de maintenance
tout le monde a été formé sur le tas
dans des bassines qui sont uniques en
france chaque série à
imagine spécifique avec un producteur
très futé donc en gros
se doit de former eux-mêmes notre
personnel en main dans les dernières
recrues sont arrivées cet été en même
temps que la nouvelle machine un robot
ultra moderne qui assemble les palettes
les deux opérateurs sont encore en
formation
jusqu'ici il n'avait jamais travaillé
dans l'industrie et que vous pouviez
avant électricien dans le bâtiment n'a
rien à voir alors qu'est ce qui est
plaisant quand on pilote une machine
comme celle ci bas le pen dehors cette
énorme machine de programmer la
programmation la mécanique
kuhn qu'elle emploie 80 personnes les
palettes sont essentiellement vendus à
des industriels dans un rayon de 300 km
la société exporte aussi deux conteneurs
chaque mois vers la chine
ce ne sont pas les débouchés qui
manquent étrangement ce qui contrarie
les affaires c'est la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre les gens qui cherchent du
travail ne sont pas forcément adaptées
aux besoins des entreprises
ou alors n'ont pas eu forcément les
bonnes formations ou sont pas situés
géographiquement au bon endroit
on pense à l'investissement avant de
penser clients ou
financement on va penser d'abord qui va
faire tourner là qui va faire tourner la
machine comme ça c'est la wii c'est la
priorité des priorités
la maison doit sans cesse s'adapter afin
de rester rentable demain par exemple
ces résidus constitueront peut-être la
principale source de revenus pour mieux
tirer profit des sur et de chutes de
bois issu de la série l'entreprise va
construire une nouvelle usine qui
abritera une centrale électrique
une unité de production de chaleur
destinée à assécher le bois et une ligne
de fabrication de granulés de bois pour
le chauffage
la société va investir 14 millions
d'euros et recruté 35 personnes d'ici
2020 comme quoi le bon sens n'interdit
pas l'audace